a toy party chair facing further
questions over his financial affairs
after his emerged he settled a dispute
with tax authorities while he was
Chancellor on Saturday Nadim zahawi said
that he'd pay the hmrc as stumbling to
what he called a careless error joined I
by the labor supporting tax expert Dan
needle who investigated Mr zahawi's
Affairs hello lady thanks for joining us
on the program this morning
on the labor supporting thing I advise
politicians of all four main parties and
I've annoyed politicians of all four
main parties our work is non-partisan
and most people respect that but what
about you do you support the labor party
you're not a labor party member
personally I support the labor party but
I keep my tax analysis and my legal work
separate from my private political views
always have done okay why did Nadeem
zahawi's tax refers first come to your
attention
so back in July there was a report in
some of the press that the NCAA the SFO
and hmrc had investigated his tax and he
denied it but then you wouldn't
necessarily know if you're being
investigated so I started looking and I
saw something very odd in the way that
his original Founders shares in newgov
were structured and from that I
concluded it looked like he had not paid
about 3.7 million in tax
he denied that he not only denied it he
threatened to sue me and other
newspapers looking at it and the whole
thing went really rather quiet until it
was revealed to just
um a week and a day ago that at the same
time he was denying it and sending
threatening letters to people
he'd actually fessed up to HMR team if
he did owe the tax and he paid it plus
penalties
foreign
spoke to me on the 11th of July last
year when he was hoping to be the next
prime minister during the leadership
battle for number 10. he said neither he
nor his wife had benefited benefited
from any offshore funds
why did you why do you sorry why do you
say that he has
so I saw that and my jaw dropped because
there was clear evidence in a Hugo of
disclosure from 2005 that we just have
it by by some corporate Quirk we see
this that he benefited because he
received 99 000 pounds from vulture
Investments held by the trust that's not
my supposition or a guess absolute fact
and Yeti denied that to you I I said to
his lawyers why is he saying this to Kay
Burley when the evidence says it's not
true
and they wouldn't reply
how much do you calculate go on sorry
come on right so start with 99 000. if
you receive 99 000 and we just
discovered it by luck it's fair to infer
there have been other payments and now
if he was as report suggest actually
taxed and paid 3.7 million I'm guessing
on about 27 million of incoming gains he
didn't declare then that suggests he
received a lot of money millions of
pounds from the trust and he told you he
didn't benefit at all
do we do we know for a fact though that
he has received more than the 99 000
pounds which you say there is a paper
trail for do we do we know that he's
received we don't know how he received
it but if he was taxed 3.7 million
pounds plus penalties and didn't receive
any money and that's a huge Injustice
and I'm behind him 100 I'm guessing he
would have said so
you don't you're not generally taxed on
money that you don't get
how much do you calculate that he has
because we don't know how much do you
calculate that he has paid to hmrc
um well we don't know but the leaks
suggested a figure of 3.7 million plus
interest and penalties and that is so
close to the figure that I estimated
that it makes me think that my original
supposition back in July was correct
so how much money do you think he's
received
I I think he will have received about 27
million pounds and not paid tax on it
until eventually he was forced to
because it was being reported didn't
admit it denied it then to see people
and went to hmrc to quietly settle it
he said that hmrc has accepted that he
made a mistake and his error was
careless and not deliberate why is that
not the end of the matter
well to say it's not deliberate as if
it's a triumphant result is a bit is a
bit funny if it was deliberate he'd be
arrested for criminal tax evasion
careless means something specific
careless means that you didn't behave in
a reasonable way a reasonable way is you
instruct decent tax advisors you tell
them the truth you follow their advice
you check your final tax returns best
you can if you do those things then even
if it turns out the tax is wrong even if
your tax advisors were total clowns
you're not careless
so if you're careless it often means you
didn't get advice at all in his case
that would mean he could have received
the money 27 million pounds perhaps not
taking advice and not paid tax if that
is what happened
that's a huge deal
um how will we find out
well we have no way to find out because
hmrc quite rightly have a duty of
confidentiality however if Mr zahari
thinks he needs to continue to be a
senior politician he owes us an honest
answer he needs to explain exactly what
happened explain exactly why he didn't
pay the tax and most importantly explain
why he told me
he told you in that interview
told pretty much everyone that his tax
Affairs were hunky-dory at the same time
that he knew they weren't
are you suggesting that he intentionally
avoided tax
now if he'd attentionally avoided tax
then that would be criminal tax evasion
and he would have been dishonest I can't
read his mind he says and I had no
reason to disbelieve him hmrc concluded
that he was careless not deliberate but
I am suggesting he deliberately didn't
tell me and you and everyone else that
there was a problem with his tax Affairs
when he knew there was and I'm also
suggesting that he told you he had no
interest in the trust when he must have
done
um
a non-deliberate error not set up an
offshore structure to avoid tax is what
the hmrc has accepted he hasn't broken
the law he has paid any outstanding
monies with a 30 penalty or thereabouts
um I suppose a lot of people watching
this morning would say surely you know
he's put his hands up he made a mistake
he's paid the money he needed to that's
it
well we we all make mistakes we are lost
a pen yesterday I had no idea where it
was
um I thought I felt ridiculous I was
using it a mistake where you don't
declare 27 million pounds
if we accept everything he says and that
wasn't intentional
that that's an amazing mistake to make
and you've got a question whether
someone who makes that mistake is
suitable for public life for me though
that's less important than the quite
deliberate fact that he when he knew
there was something wrong with his tax
affairs
sent lawyers after me and others trying
to report on it and told you that he had
no interest in a trust which he surely
did and then say we should come to the
bit that you mentioned earlier that I I
haven't picked up best of all worst of
all
he went to hmrc to negotiate a
settlement
when he was Chancellor of the exchequer
so what do you want to happen
it could be there's an innocent
explanation for this which makes perfect
sense I lack the imagination to see it
and if there isn't one I think it should
resign
foreign
a tweet that you you I think it was
yesterday
um you say um that Mr sahari's lawyers
have written to you denying that hmrc
investigated him under cop nine the
procedure for investigating
fraud
um
just explain that to me
well I was interested in his in his
statement he said they concluded it
wasn't deliberate it was a mistake which
suggested perhaps they thought at one
point it was deliberate so I asked him
do what did it start out as a fraud
investigation and he said no
okay
um I've I've seen a note from Mr
zahawi's lawyers um responding to you
saying that Mr Tsar was not being
investigated for fraud so his tax
repayment was not being blown out of
proportion since it's not being
considered currently
um as anything criminal is that
reasonable to say
if everything he says is true then then
yes it wasn't Criminal it was it was a
careless mistake but I think we want
higher standards from our politicians
than not being criminal don't we we seem
to be at somewhat of a standoff though
don't we because you you want him to
come clean and basically to resign
because you feel that when he was
Chancellor you can't have any uh
investigation by hmrc even though you
said that he probably didn't know uh
initially that he's his tax Affairs were
being investigated while your Chancellor
so
um what would be okay how do you how do
you feel okay that he you asked him a
direct question and he gave you an
answer which is absolutely false when it
comes to the 99 000 pound and he knew
that and which is almost certainly false
given he's paying the tax how have you
had a politician give you an answer
which which we know was false has that
happened before
many many many times I'm crashingly died
I was sure many times but you know
you're telling me that he was being
economical with the actuality when he
was speaking uh to me you say that
you've got this figure of 99 000 pounds
and you can then leap and surmise that
potentially uh he benefited in the form
of 27 million friends but what I'm
saying is if you find the 99 000 why why
can you not find the rest oh the only
way we find the 99
000 is there was accidentally an
unlawful loan made to the directors it's
a mistake it happens all the time and
that was repaid via a gift and because
it had been an unlawful loan the way it
was repaid is disclosed until 2005
documents it's a complete fluke we we
can find that out normally we'd have no
way to see the gifts
what you want him to resign because you
feel that he hasn't behaved
appropriately while in public office he
threatened to sue me for reporting on
something which he denied and turns out
to be true I I don't think politicians
should do that
uh what's going to happen next
well I expect people will keep asking
him to come clean and he will either
come clean and provide a satisfactory
explanation and I will eat to my
collection of hats or he won't come
clean and will have to resign
and the 99
000 pounds which is the only figures
that you can find at the moment we don't
even know how much he's paid to hmrc or
if indeed he has but he says that he's
paid some we don't know if that includes
a fine or or not oh we do because he
admits being careless which absolutely
means there was a penalty the word
careless has a particular tax meaning
okay okay I didn't understand that thank
you for explaining that
um you will continue on with this though
will you until you try to uncover more
funds or have to eat those hats
I will this I prefer doing nerdy tax
policy that hardly anyone reads but I'm
not going to let this draw
okay it's good to talk to you thank you
very much indeed for joining us on the
program thank you thank you very much